je suis un enfant des trente glorieuses
et que nous allons tour de 68 je
commence mon livre comme ça évidemment
la nation était au plus bas
enfin au plus bas dans les élites
intellectuelles occidentale mais ça fait
déjà beaucoup de monde et c'était le
mieux le milieu étudiant etc
universitaire dans lequel je me
déplaçais puisque la nation c'était le
passé évidemment oui au 19e siècle
éventuellement mais depuis la révolution
de 1917
depuis la victoire sur le fascisme en 45
depuis la décolonisation bien la nation
c'était le passé et ça ne serait jamais
l'avenir
d'autre part la nation s'est elle mal
puisque ça débouchait sur le
nationalisme donc la xénophobie pourquoi
pas le racisme
et puis plus subtilement dans dans ce
milieu intellectuel et ceux qui ont fait
des études universitaires
une croisée la notion de nation ils sont
tombés sur ce genre de livre vous aviez
benedict anderson vous aviez gallner
vous avez ensuite hobsbawm qui vous
disaient la nation je nie pas ses
mystifications mais c'est une
construction
sous-entendu ça n'a rien de deux très
justifié ces inauthentique résultat
c'est qu'aujourd'hui où on se parle
frédéric vous et moi
la nation c'est le présent est
clairement celle à venir quand on voit à
la surface de la planète toutes les
grandes questions nationales qui dispose
de l'ecosse à la catalogne en passant
par le kurdistan
les trois chine l'avenir de taïwan etc
d'autre part la nation on voit bien les
salles le livre essaie de le démontrer
dans les premiers chapitres qu'elle
vient entre guillemets de la gauche
puisque c'est lié à une sorte de
révolution
vous l'avez dit à juste titre il ya
environ 3 4 siècles une révolution
politique moderne dans laquelle on est
encore à savoir la souveraineté
populaire c'est ça qui fondent la nation
et enfin le côté construit mais oui bien
sûr mais comme toutes les institutions
politiques
elles ont besoin d'être construite et
l'internationalisme le mondialisme s'est
aussi construit que l'hymne national
[Musique]